(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And finally, New Rule,
this dangerous idea
that has taken root in America,
that something is true
merely because you want
to believe it's true,
has gotta go.
-I... (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
I have spent
an awful lot of time
on this show in the pre-Trump,
and they--
then the Trump presidency years
trying to convince people
that this man
would never concede
losing an election,
no matter what the truth was.
And what made me so sure of that
was that America
had become a place
where truth no longer mattered.
It was all about whether
it felt right in your gut.
"Donald Trump lost to Joe Biden?
That can't be right."
(SCOFFS) That's what many
of his fans said and still do.
Any time an issue
didn't go their way,
the response would be...
(SCOFFS) "...crisis actors.
That's what that was,
fucking crisis actors."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
"False flag operations,
the deep state."
When the Right does this,
we call it conspiracy theories,
and rightly so.
When the Left does it,
we call it emotional truth.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Which brings me to Hasan Minhaj,
the comedian
who answers the question,
"What if Jussie Smollett
did stand-up?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
If you missed it,
The New Yorker recently ran
a comprehensive exposé
about how many of the stories
Mr. Minhaj tells
in his act to elicit sympathy
for himself as a Muslim
and a person of color
are completely made up.
Now, let's pause here
to acknowledge
that Muslims and people of color
in America have,
of course, faced prejudice
and discrimination.
And this country
has a racial history
that is nothing short
of despicable.
And some of it
continues to this day.
The question
I'm always asking is,
"Where exactly are we
with this now?"
Because it's not as good
as the Right says it is.
And I think it's also not as bad
as the Left says.
But if you have
to fabricate the stories
of your mistreatment,
isn't that itself a comment
-on where we are now?
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
One of Mr. Minhaj's stories
is about a White girl
he asked to the prom
who spurned him on the big day
when her parents
didn't want pictures taken
with a Brown boy,
except it never happened.
Then there was the time
the FBI hunted him down
as a suspected terrorist
and threw him
against the hood of a car,
except for the part
where they didn't do that
at all.
The New Yorker writer
who interviewed Minhaj asks,
"Does it matter
that neither of those things
really happened?"
-Yes...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-...Yes, it does matter.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
It does matter.
If... If you wanna speak truth
to power,
I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say you have to include
-the truth part.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
Because he's done this
before with me...
(CLEARS THROAT) ...accusing me
of saying Muslims should be put
in internment camps,
something I've never come close
to thinking, let alone saying.
And it's an odd thing to claim,
given that this show is,
you know, recorded
with cameras and audio.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So, I ask you, a guy saying,
he saw me saying,
"Round up the Muslims" on TV,
even though I never did,
how is that different
than this guy?
And I watched in Jersey City,
New Jersey,
where thousands and thousands
of people were cheering
as that building
was coming down.
-(SCOFFS)
-(AUDIENCE MEMBER CHUCKLES)
This country needs
to make a grand bargain.
Bullshit is bad,
no matter who says it,
-or what you call it.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Minhaj says,
"The emotional truth is first,
the factual truth is secondary."
That's the part of the zeitgeist
he has captured.
That it's all about getting
to the truth man,
and what better way to do that
than by lying.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I think the younger generations
have a real problem
with wanting
to build their identity
around being a victim.
They wanna have racism to fight,
not fight racism,
have racism to fight so badly
that when it's not there,
they make it up.
And there's enough real racism
in the world
that making up more
doesn't help.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
-(CLEARS THROAT)
Minhaj told The New Yorker
that his actual life
was too dull to provide
juicy material
-for his acts.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Isn't that a good thing?
He seems to literally feel
cheated by progress.
-The pro--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The progress that has denied him
any good stories
about being oppressed
by the man.
Dude, America is far
from the worst.
You're a Muslim
married to a Hindu.
If you were living in India,
she'd have to murder you.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(BILL MAHER CLEARING THROAT)
And that prom date
that he talks about,
he didn't disguise
her identity very well,
and now, she has had to deal
with death threats and doxing.
There are consequences to lying
and funny side story,
you know who she married?
Another Indian guy.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Hearing that,
even Minhaj himself must know,
"Man,
if people don't like you now,
it's probably not because
you're a person of color,
it's because you're shady."